Well,
you know,
one of the things that,
that people have pointed out over
the last year is that I'm better,
let's say when I'm less angry and some
of that is poor health am I helped,
has been,
I've had periods of very
bad health in the last year,
like dreadfully bad for,
for months on end.
And although that seems
to have resolved itself,
thank God,
knock on wood and all of that,
um,
I do know that you're not a master of
a serious topic until you can handle it
with play,
the fullness and lightness and that
that goes for even the most serious of
topics.
And so one of the things that I would
hope is that I can keep my head more
effectively in the next year and let
some of this roll off my back and not
respond quite.
So.
What would you say fit viciously?
Maybe.
Maybe that's it.
You know,
there's,
there's common English common law rule,
which I write about in 12 rules of life,
which is that you're not supposed
to respond with any more forced than
necessary.
And I think that there have been times
in the last year that I've responded with
more force than was necessary.
It wasn't easy to tell,
you know,
because sometimes the forces that were
brought them to bear on me seem quite
intimidating,
but it's,
it's an art to respond judiciously.
And so hopefully I can learn how to
do that better in the upcoming year.
But tabbing lived,
breathed,
and worked with a feminist
and radical leftist Marxists,
I'm telling you,
being mellow and calm
with them doesn't work.
And they're almost like,
um,
what am I going to say?
A pack of wolves at times
the way they attack.
Well,
that's the thing,
it's,
it's harder.
It's harder under conditions of mob
attack to remain cool and to remain and to
retain your head.
But you know,
when I was at McMaster,
which was probably the most
extreme demonstration against me,
I was able to stay calm
and that really was useful.
It was unbelievably useful.
It was the right way to handle that.
And so I just have to,
well,
in not being ill helps a
lot too because you know,
if your health is compromised,
it's a lot more,
it's a lot easier to be touchy and,
and also to make errors in judgment.
And so hopefully I'll be back
on both feet for the next year.
That would be a good thing and won't
be inclined to make errors because of
fatigue or,
or,
uh,
will you be tweeting from Europe then
putting up your videos for all of us who
will miss you so much here and we want
to keep up to date on what you're doing
and what you're working on.
I want to stay on top of my youtube
channel and the podcasts and all of that,
so I'll definitely be doing that.
So.